lighting up social media is queen of the
clap back a modern art installation
demeans the first daughter and
ten-year-old Cub Scout taking Annie
joining us with all the details Raymond
Arroyo Fox News contributor New York
Times bestselling author of the upcoming
book almost out well Wilder that we
cumulative power Raymond now Pelosi did
her very best to show the president's
Thunder last night but it's the clap
back that's getting all the attention
we're hitting the news that all of you
really need here at Fox well but a lot
of people didn't see this anyone who
watch the State of the Union and is
familiar with speaker Pelosi attempts to
kind of steal the focus all evening
realize that she's perfected the art of
subtle contempt or maybe she just needs
some fix it in whatever the case
she was gnawing on something in her
mouth all evening was it a Luden's beef
jerkey we may never know her several
time she pulled out what might have been
a large menu and she looked like she was
trying to decide whether to have the
foie gras or the pea soup or maybe she's
reading Obamacare we don't know your
Brown right but now all right Nancy
Pelosi's mouth tick seems to be catching
this is Kamala Harris lore reacting to
the president's calls to put coyotes out
of business at the border look at her
mouth oh she's doing she's got the mouth
tick but not you know it's it's
spreading but nothing quite caught the
attention of Democrats as this moment at
the State of the Union it's being called
the Nancy clap bag what
kind of this you see it's this extended
of shoulders up now they're reading a
lot into this Pelosi starter Christine
took to Twitter to say oh yes that clap
back took me back to the teen years she
knows and she knows that you know and
frankly she's disappointed that you
thought it would work for you why don't
we care about what Christine polo sees
you know we'll walk down memory lane
with mommy so I'll tell you what this is
really about scold she was the scold
then and she's ask old man wahoo OHS had
an article on this the exquisite shade
of Nancy Pelosi's applaud this is
Democrats Esprit for something good
something a good night for the president
and let me tell you the other point here
when stacey abrams is your mouthpiece
nancy pelosi clapping seems like maria
callas in the last act of Tosca okay
they're looking for help they're looking
for something they can a bit of
performance on it can latch on to by the
way I couldn't sleep last night yeah we
were up so late during the show and I
kept thinking of that commercial hmm was
it kid French is the world-class clapper
721 claps a minute with the clapper I
only need two claps claps things on
glass things up so when they lose the
majority of the house in 2020 she can be
the new burger know that bond I also
thought maybe it may not be anything
conscious she might have just been kind
of osteoporosis or something and she's
just clapping it might just be the way
she claps anyway Laura there is a new
exhibit talking a performing art exhibit
that just goes Emperor Washington it's
called
evanka vacuuming that's right and Ivanka
Trump look-alike is in a gallery and
patrons are invited to throw crumbs of
her trash that she will vacuum up the
gallery says quote Ivanka vacuuming is
simultaneously a visual celebration of a
contemporary feminine icon a portrait of
our own relationship to that figure and
a questioning of our complicity in her
role-playing you know what I discovered
about this cultural decorative group
putting this on not only is it sexist
and misogynist
this group is taxpayer-funded they got a
hundred and twenty thousand dollars in
government funding in 2016
imagine if they put Michelle Obama and
people were encouraged to throw a
produce at her
a garden or let's say Hillary Clinton
where you throw email servers at her and
she picks them up that would be seen as
what it is sexist misogynist and inhuman
this stuff should not stand this is
really you know I never was big into
performance art it's always like there's
a there's a there's like a woman with a
red dot on the wall and she stares that
it was a woman vacuuming art this is
called domestic chores we have to do
this yeah and they did it to Michelle
the protests out front you're right now
finally a Cub Scout Wow my kids were in
Cub Scout see him right there is cutie
he took a knee at a city council meeting
in North Carolina during the national
anthem
local media picked up on the story the
kid and his father explained the stunt
this way
what I do is took Annie against racial
discrimination which is basically what
people are mean to other people of
different colors and he did it I was
really surprised and also really proud
of him the father discussed this with
him beforehand and he says I'm in the
City Council said I'm glad the kids
showed exercised his conscience this is
not conscience this is propaganda and
political child abuse I'm sorry it's
like he's not an NFL player the reason
for him to kneel if he wants to protest
go with go help poor people or better
yet take your club Cub Scout troop go to
the inner city and help people out baby
did you worried about races do more a
lot of veterans I saw comment a lot of
good veterans like I was in Eagle Scouts
saying our whole thing is patriotism
right patriotism and service to others
yeah and lucky so he's daddy had the
little daddy is like using a little pawn
there I don't that's that